hi welcome to another cold fusion video
it goes without saying that the mobile
phone industry has evolved immensely in
the past two decades
but along the way there's been some
interesting stories of catastrophic
business failures and horrible phone
designs
one such business failure lost its
parent company one
billion dollars the device that caused
this loss was on the market for just two
months
another phone company failure saw its
founder jailed for fraud
in this video we'll take a look at some
of these crazy stories and some other
cell phone oddities
hopefully this video will be a fun one
for you guys you are watching cold
fusion tv
in 2011 rumors of an amazon phone
started circulating
imagine if amazon one of the largest
tech companies on earth
released a phone a phone that was
aggressively priced and had simple
software
android was relatively new at the time
and this new amazon phone could pose a
real threat to the iphone
and other android phones to add to this
ceo
jeff bezos was deeply involved in this
amazon phone's development
the phone which would eventually be
called the amazon fire phone
ended up costing 650 us dollars about
the same as other flagship phones
so what did you get for that well there
were no google apps
and most of the android apps didn't
exist it had unrefined software
poor battery life and sluggish
performance
the fire phone did have one unique
feature though
its five front-facing cameras could
track your head and give you contextual
3d effects
the result is that the display could
make it seem like things were popping
out at you
there was also a button for identifying
things in the real world
and instantly getting amazon to deliver
it to you but these features weren't
useful enough to gain customers
it took just three months for amazon to
admit defeat and accept
a 170 million dollar loss
the nokia n gauge was a mobile phone
that doubled as a handheld game console
its design is instantly recognizable to
millions so you would think it was
successful
or during its development it seemed like
it could be
portable gaming was entering a new phase
with the sony playstation
portable and nintendo ds both coming out
the next year
unfortunately for nokia the n-gage was
neither good at gaming
and it made a very awkward phone the
sales suffered because of this
in fact nokia were caught lying about
the numbers
they claimed 400 000 units had been sold
in the first two weeks
the true number however was around 6 000
but nokia was counting the shipped unit
as sales
the ill-fated phone would be
discontinued in 2005.
imagine being able to sell a full
smartphone for only four us dollars
this is what the indian company ringing
bells tried to do with their freedom 251
phone
in 2016 it was ranked the number one
searched android phone
the company made a huge promise
attracted tons of attention
and as a result they earned a whole
bunch of four dollar pre-orders in
india but there was a problem the
company wanted the government to support
them to a tune
of 7.4 billion dollars so what was in it
for the government
well the plan was to connect hundreds of
millions of indians to the online world
through cheap smartphones that they
otherwise couldn't afford
the ringing bells company stated that
their true goal was to help empower
indian people
at the time the indian government was
doing just that they launched a project
called digital india
its aim was to give cheap internet to
the majority of the nation
so such a deal with the government
wasn't unfeasible
but meanwhile ringing bells was losing
13 per unit in production
the plan was to use advertising and
in-app deals to make up the cost
but even with those deals they were
still going to lose four dollars a unit
the grand reveal of the phone
highlighted the reality
it turned out that the handset was
actually an existing cheap
chinese phone manufactured by the brand
adcom
they had simply used whiteout marker to
cover the adcom branding
it's the freedom 251 and it's called 251
because in india it costs 251
rupees which comes to 3.70 cents here
but when you look closer at the facts
around this phone things start to get
super shady and it's clear something is
not right
for starters the company ringing bells
says it's made in india but is in fact
made in china
when the phone was unveiled at a press
event reporters were given
sample phones that had the chinese brand
adcom
covered in whiteout you can see the
paint scratched off here in this video
from the business newspaper mint
in which the reporter also said she had
trouble getting the review model to turn
on
and photos from various news outlets all
show icons on the home screen that look
like they were ripped off from apple's
iphone app icons
india's telecom ministry is
investigating this company and how it
could possibly sell a phone for so cheap
the government deal eventually fell
through and the pre-orders were never
fulfilled
mohit goel who was spearheading the
project was arrested and charged with
fraud
some analysts have since called the
phone a classic ponzi scheme
the idea of a smartwatch has been around
since the early 90s
but in 2004 the korean firm telson
tried to push it all a step forward with
the twc
1150 it was truly something
special a vision of the year 3000 from
2004
the only thing was it looked ridiculous
to most people
and holding your wrist up to your head
when receiving a phone call
was less than intuitive but props for
the effort
bang and olsen is well known for their
high end audio and in 2005
they teamed up with samsung to launch
their serene phone
it was specifically designed to compete
with high-end phones on the market
namely the top nokias it had an
interesting design
that included a power assistant hinge
and now that it's on
you'll be able to hear the mechanical
[Music]
aid of the the hinge there
it also featured an ipod style scroll
wheel and an lcd display
but due to its unfortunate design taking
photos was awkward
because the camera was in the hinge the
device was a hard sell
at two thousand dollars unsurprisingly
it wasn't terribly popular
though i'm sure it's going to be a
collector's item soon
in 2011 to stand out from the crowded
field of android phones
the japanese firm kyocera tried to think
different with their echo phone
the echo featured a secondary and equal
3.5 inch screen
that moved outwards on a hinge users
could select
two of seven apps to run simultaneously
they could also stretch out individual
apps to cover both displays
looking at this they were close to the
right idea but the technology just
wasn't ready like you would a normal
smartphone you can actually change the
orientation too so let's
tilt it you notice it works in both
both the viewing area styles both
portrait and landscape
again you'll see the speed of how fast
this thing really moves
users ended up with slow bulky hardware
a massive seam in the middle
and weak battery life from trying to
power two screens
to add to this the software of the apps
was poorly optimized
today dual screen phones are making a
comeback so maybe this time around
kyocera
wouldn't it be cool if your phone could
double as a widescreen projector
that was the plan for 2012 samsung
galaxy beam
yes it was an android phone with a
built-in mini projector
i thought this would be the next big
thing when i first saw it eight years
ago
end gadget reviewers of the time said it
was actually great for watching netflix
and other content in a dark room
quote at first we couldn't think of many
uses
outside of a businessman using it for
presentations but it actually came in
handy than we expected
i watch movies on the wall and the
ceiling before falling asleep
a convenient option since the projector
was larger than the tv i had laying
around
to be honest if a company could do this
right i actually still think it's a good
idea
unfortunately for samsung the galaxy
beam ended up being a footnote in tech
history
[Music]
the company red has a stellar reputation
for its high quality camera equipment
in fact the majority of netflix shows
are shot on red cameras
so obviously this company would be able
to make a hit smartphone with a great
camera
well that's what most people thought but
their phone
the red hydrogen one went in a strange
direction
its main selling point was a
glasses-free 3d
holographic display the phone didn't
have much else going for it
reviewers hated its dim display bulky
construction
and subpar camera performance and at 1
300
it was a complete flop and just two
years later you can get a brand new one
for 300 us dollars
the company planned to release
expandable add-on modules but these
never came
and have even since disappeared from the
company's promotional materials
okay so now we come to the biggest
mobile phone failure of all time
in 2010 microsoft was planning to do
something different in the mobile space
with their kin phones manufactured by
sharp on behalf of microsoft these
phones were targeted at social
networking teens
unfortunately the promotional marketing
came across as an old man pretending to
be hip
this was the least of the kin's problems
though the phone didn't have an app
store so
it wasn't a real smartphone but despite
this the social networking focus meant
that buyers needed a data plan
this made it too expensive for its
target market
but that wasn't all the kin phones ended
up being slow buggy
poorly built and had a low resolution
screen
even microsoft's san francisco launch
event felt half-hearted
as if the company knew it was making a
[Music]
mistake
uh good morning everybody this
generation let's call it the social
generation
really does have a point of view they
think it
they do it and they have a mantra for it
and so we
we try to categorize and understand
their needs and i think there's sort of
three things that that pop for us in a
big way
and when we thought about that we kind
of came up with this this concept of
friends friends and friends
there was one thing about the kin that i
thought was interesting however
it featured a permanent green dot that
stayed at the bottom of the interface
it behaved like a scrapbook where you
could drop items like tweets
photos messages and other information to
share with people
it was always there so you didn't have
to go into an app or dig into a menu to
find something that you'd save for later
if modern smartphones had something
similar but not necessarily only for
sharing
i think it would be a solid idea but
despite this
the kin phones were a disaster it only
lasted
48 days on the market before microsoft
killed it
as it turned out there were internal
struggles between the microsoft kin team
and the upcoming windows phone team
ultimately microsoft didn't want this
laggy phone to be associated with their
upcoming windows phone 7 efforts
windows phone was another venture by
microsoft that was well executed but
unfortunately also failed in the end
the microsoft kin project lost the
company over one
billion dollars in development costs
this makes it probably the most costly
disaster in mobile history
and before we go a couple of honorable
mentions of course the samsung galaxy
note 7 in 2016
we all know that story a battery defect
caused units to explode and uses pockets
and the phone was even banned on flight
the nokia 7280 this 2005 phone was
shaped like a tube
and affectionately nicknamed the
lipstick phone it didn't have a dial pad
and you had to enter numbers on an ipod
like scroll wheel
it was slow and tedious to use a truly
unique phone but too impractical to be a
hit
i included these last two in the video
because they're just insane
the c999 star phone is a bizarre phone
out of china from around 2009
the device was unquestionably
unpractical
pretty much its main selling point was
that it was shaped like a star
and finally in the honorable mentions
the golden buddha phone
the golden buddha phone was another
chinese marvel
coming with a 24 carat gold exterior
interplanetary design
and a price tag 1750 us dollars
it's safe to say that this is the
craziest phone i've ever seen
so that's it for this video let me know
in the comments section which phone
stood out to you as the biggest disaster
if you did like this video and want to
see anything on science
technology business or history feel free
to subscribe to this channel
there's heaps of content on here and if
you want to see more throwback crazy
phones
check out the mr mobile series when
phones were fun
i think he's doing a great job in
covering some of those so i'll leave a
link for that
in the description next week in the next
episode
we'll take a deep dive into the recent
wirecard scandal
the biggest financial fraud in european
history
alright so that's it thanks for watching
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next video cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
[Music]
you